[Music]
avengers
assemble
welcome to your weekly ticket
last week sources reported that captain
america aka chris evans will be
returning to the
mcu reports suggest that evans would
return in at least
one marvel property with the door open
for a second if
evans was actually eyeing a return to
captain america he definitely played coy
on social media tweeting out
news to me with a shrug emoji whatever
the plan may be steve rogers returning
seems to be
a popular idea according to the
internet's reaction to the news
hannah flint replied saying give the
people what they want a steve and peggy
rom-com about how they got back together
in the past are rated it's also a
musical
brandon davis bd chimed in with put on
the suit
and finally billy eichner weighed in
saying i'll do it
and david o'russell has cast nearly
everyone in hollywood
in his new film deadline reports that
anya taylor joy robert de niro mike
myers timothy oliphant michael shannon
and chris rock are set to appear
and that's on top of the previous
casting announcement of christian bale
margot robbie john david washington rami
malik and zoe saldana
while plot details for the untitled film
are not yet known
we do know it's an original idea from
the five-time oscar-nominated writer
director
which will be the director's first film
since 2015's
joy and brandon frazier is set to star
in darren aronofsky's new film
the whale which will be frasier's first
leading theatrical film role in nearly a
decade
the film will also mark aronofsky's
first film since 2017's mother
his first for a24 the film is based on
the 2012 samuel d
hunter play of the same name set in the
mormon county of idaho fraser will play
a 600 pound gay man who can't leave his
apartment
and is estranged from his teenage
daughter who he attempts to reconnect
with
hunter said this story is deeply
personal and i'm very thankful it will
have a chance to reach a wider audience
i've been a fan of darren's ever since i
saw requiem for a dream when i was a
college freshman
writing my first plays and i'm so
grateful that he's bringing his singular
talent and his vision to this film
today we're celebrating the release of
the kid detective by talking to the film
star adam brody
adam thanks for coming on weekly ticket
man thanks for having me
now you've been attached to this film
for quite some time what drew you to the
role
the strength of the writing uh evan
morgan writer director he's just got a
very sharp
very funny very melancholic unique voice
and then
i love the premise it's a high concept
premise and a you know low budget movie
a heightened world and so it plays with
on one hand this very hollywood sort of
idea and on the other hand low budget
movie and a lot of hidden
depth and it's comedic it's dramatic
it's just so many things that that i
really respond to but mostly
above all he's just great writer is it
hard to balance that sort of
humor with the darker undertones like
murder and kidnapping
yeah very much and in fact we had a lot
of productive clashes throughout the
filming of it where
uh you know he'd always bring it down
and i would always kind of want to
play a little and he'd want it more
subdued and i think we ended up kind of
in the middle
so you know it was a successful
collaboration but it was a constant
negotiation
is there one scene that you're uh you're
glad that you got to kind of
bring to your level mostly he pulled it
to his level but
he he won on most of it and i just
thought well this movie's going to live
or die with his
the strength of his you know choices
either he's right or
if he's wrong and i'm right the movie's
still not going to be good because he's
either got to have it or he doesn't so
i'll
mostly acquiesce to him but um you know
there's a few
a bit of there's a couple yells that
were mine and
i told let's even in edits was like
let's try that or let's put that one
back in and so
the few times i raised my voice i'm
happy that's in there but mostly he won
well they can release like a yell
edition that's yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right cool um so
there's so many detective films out
there what do you think makes a good
detective film
you know i don't watch them as puzzles
necessarily personally you know i i
some people do some people are all about
trying to solve and that you know i
i want to be surprised at the end i want
to not see it coming
but i don't even have to really follow
the how or why of it
you know some of my favorite ones i i
don't understand
but i just think colorful characters i
think you got to have
colorful characters and you got to have
danger and you got to have humor
mostly you don't always have to have
humor but i think most of my favorites
do
certainly some great ones don't have are
pretty dead serious so i guess it
depends if you're going if it's leaning
more comedy or more
you know the the less comedic you are
the more it's gonna have to be the
straight you know lean into the strength
of the
story if you thought i was gonna let you
get away without telling me what some of
your favorites
are you got another thing coming what
are your favorites well chinatown on one
hand
we talked a lot about the long goodbye
with this movie we like the longer bylaw
and that's you know
dark but has you know real comedic you
know a lot of comedy in there too
kiss kiss bang bang has been a favorite
for a long time
yeah you know i saw this one a couple
years ago gemini i saw it on a plane it
was so good
small one with lola kirk is her name and
zoe kravitz and i thought it was great
there's another small detective one that
i i really enjoyed well you know a lot
of us are spending a lot of time at home
is there any movie that you've streamed
at home that you've particularly enjoyed
earlier this year of new movies i like
the invisible man a lot i thought that
was good
it was just like good popcorn it's a
good hollywood horror movie it was
neat this year honestly i'd never seen
sound of music
and now i've seen it like 20 times
mostly because my daughter but also it's
like my favorite movie it's just the
best
which song from that movie gets stuck in
your head the most would you say
um that's a good question they rotate on
what my
what what the crew is singing around my
house like it sort of rotates they're
all
really but i mean that's the strength of
a good musical is that they all
you know they all have their moment and
so i can't say
one more than the other all right man
well uh thanks for talking to us
all right i appreciate it thanks a lot
available to watch at home today is the
kid detective
so what can i help you with somebody
murdered my boyfriend
seriously pretty seriously he was
stabbed 17 times
a once celebrated kid detective
continues to solve the same trivial
mysteries between hangovers and bouts of
self-pity
but a naive client brings him his first
adult case
to find out who brutally murdered her
boyfriend the film stars adam brody
sophie nelisse and sarah sutherland
and available to watch at home today is
the climb
mike's in the living room he got fat
right yeah
merry christmas rich scissors
oh my god is that mike you got fat
kyle and mike are best friends who share
a close bond until mike sleeps with
kyle's fiance
the film follows their tumultuous but
enduring relationship across many years
of laughter
heartbreak and rage it's also the story
of real-life best friends who turn their
profound connection into a rich film
about the boundaries or lack thereof
in all close friendships alright well
that's it for today but leave us a
comment and let us know what you'll be
watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]